c'est un débat s'amorce j'adore le
jean-michel à peu près jamais celle à
peu près jamais qualité qui nous
explique très bien
alors maintenant on va baisser à lumière
vous bougiez pavant le jingle
on va faire avec kad et olivier qui a
quelque chose à vous ça vous surprendra
pas parce que souvent j'ai vu des choses
de ce type dans le grand cabaret une
mission un succès que vous présentez sur
france 2 patrick sébastien
alors on va faire une interview
télépathie donc je vais vous poser des
questions par télépathie et vous allez
répondre à cet effet à la télévision
dans ce col est tellement maintenant
c'est alors clotilde si c'est pour nous
déconcentrer ça va pas le faire après je
ferai un petit peu avec olivier ça
marche aussi bien qui est de toute façon
interview télépathie première question
répondent et 31 cm au repos c'est qu'on
parle pas de moi maintenant dans l'est
là je me déconcentre vous plaît c'est
compliqué deuxième question tu peux
répéter la fin la question
non non je trouve pas que sébastien soit
ringard pas d'accord avec toi thierry
bien à vous maintenant [ __ ] un accent
tu vas voir ah ouais ouais je peux te
faire la barre est à 200 balles si tu
veux et donc de barétous dernière
question
linda hardy
bravo bravo rallume la lumière calais
olivier l'interview télé c'est
exceptionnel